avoid gaming which has 10 hotels across
las vegas including the aliante gold
coast sam's town and fremont hotel gave
a positive update
on its third quarter results at its
properties now when property started
reopening the las vegas locals business
started soft and slow in june
but as it's grown the company says it's
gotten stronger and better at
determining what has worked and what
hasn't
the company says it has developed and
implemented entirely new safety and
sanitation measures it has successfully
executed
and this was one of the greatest
challenges the company has ever faced
overall our business has been remarkably
stable since we reopened our properties
with more than 90 percent of our
business coming from customers who live
within driving distance to our
properties
we've been able to successfully execute
a strategy built on visitation
from our premium regional customers the
one property however not achieving its
best performance is the orleans as it's
been negatively impacted by no
convention business
however boyd gaming says the downtown
segment only represents about
six percent of its business across the
nation void gaming also adds it was able
to expand its digital presence during
this time with its continued expansion
of fanduel to sports bettors across the
country denise